mercialys jugement souhaitait c'était
très très important d'entendre les
conclusions dany genevard julien aubert
bruno le maire sur ce point du récit
auquel nous sommes extrêmement sensibles
aux républicains le président des
républicains s'est aussi exprimé là
dessus on ne peut pas laisser perdurer
des systèmes administratifs si au fond
un biotope public autour d'entreprises
qu'ils soient profondément négatif et le
rsi aujourd'hui amène des indépendants
soit ne plus avoir de couverture soit
avoir des demandes de cotisation
totalement hystérique
bref ils ne peuvent pas avoir confiance
dans leur système administrative qui
assurent leur protection sociale est
évidemment tout ça à coups de boutoir
c'est-à-dire de punition ou d'ordre de
faire ou de ne pas faire
enfin ils sont perdus et c'est autant de
temps qu'ils ne passent pas dans leurs
petites entreprises et le travail
indépendant est un travail qui va se
développer dans la société à venir et
donc il fallait le dire et nous voulons
le réaffirmer j'aurais peut-être demandé
à nos deux mais nos deux chefs
d'entreprises qui sont ici quelles sont
les mesures que vous considériez comme
absolument nécessaire de prendre pour
bien réformer ou bien refonder ce code
du travail si vous aviez à choisir dans
la multitude des sujets qui ont été
évoqués ce matin qu'elles sont de votre
point de vue et du point de vue de votre
entreprise ce qui vous aiderait le plus
d'abord les 35 heures que d'une
aberration complète on travaille 39 chez
nous ça entraîne un problème ce sont les
rtt qui sont aberrantes aussi un sauf
pour le tourisme que 18 très modéré on
n'a pas entendu sur les 35 heures et on
travaille 39 eur et les cadres eux et
les agents de maîtrise qui ne
travaillent pas 39 heures ont droit eux
rtt qui est un peu une aberration entre
ceux qui travaillent je travaille pas
donc moi je pense qu'il faut passer à 39
heures ça c'est le premier point
deuxièmement c'est
disons le lien qui peut y avoir entre
légende et entre l'entreprise et
l'entreprise c'est à dire le problème
qu'on peut avoir avec les syndicats
quand vous considérez que nous avons
quatre différents syndicats qui reprend
le moins de cinq personnes cinq pour
cent des personnes travaillant dans
l'entreprise c'est une aberration
complète car c'est avec eux que
discutons les augmentations de salaires
etc etc
ça c'est quelque chose de profondément a
changé nous avons aussi un autre
problème à notre problème c'est l'entrée
et la sortie des
et on en a parlé longuement faciliter
l'entrée avec disons les contrats de
travail parce que hier aussi mon
directeur des relations humaines me
disait vous savez vous des employés qui
sont là depuis trente ans le contrat de
travail il faudrait leur faire s'il
n'est plus du tout adaptée donc et
ensuite a sorti si il est impossible
quasiment de licencier souvent là je
comprends ce que dit monsieur cameron je
vous fais un tapis un tapis rouge pour
partir en angleterre donc sa saison ses
principales voici au point troisièmement
je veux dire que en ce qui concerne
un problème plus important c'est le côté
juridique nous le gagnons quasiment à
80% aux prud'hommes et nous perdons à
90% en appel je me demande pourquoi nous
avons eu un cas dans lequel aux
prud'hommes
le salarié demander la lune et on le il
a été dit aux prud'hommes que nos
sociétés n'était pas la française des
jeux et bien nous avons perdu deux cent
mille euros un appel dont nous étions la
française des jeux
mais oui c'est merci merci merci
monsieur de monsieur falco quelles sont
les mesures les deux mesures que vous
estimez riez utile de prendre rapidement
pour refonder ce code du travail
toujours vu de votre entreprise parce
que chacun évidemment sa propre avant
que nicolas sarkozy ii conclu ces
journées évidemment je rejoins
évidemment mon collègue sur les zones où
on met en hôtellerie c'est un peu
particulier parce qu'on n'a pas trente
cinq heures en irlande et on est déjà on
est déjà 39 dans le cadre de la
législation en tant que tel mais s'il y
avait vraiment quelque chose à faire
c'est simplifier s'il vous plaît
simplifiée et c'est vous demander une
mesure c'est très difficile puisqu'il ya
tellement il ya tellement de choses à
faire que c'est compliqué de le résumer
en ligne si on doit le résumer en un
seul mot ou en une phrase s'il vous
plaît chez vaut la peine non c'est ce
que vous avez dit tout à l'heure
non laissez nous bosser décennaux
gauzère si vous nous laissez bosser si
vous nous laissez bosser on va on va
embaucher du monde on va embaucher du
monde on va créer de la croissance c'est
une réalité
faites nous confiance et à un moment
donné faites confiance à l'employeur
fait confiance aux salariés de
l'entreprise
laissez-nous gérer les problèmes avec
nos collaborateurs pardon mais on les
connaît mieux que n'importe qui on les
connaît mieux que législateur j'ai bien
compris qu effectivement à l'assemblée
et au sénat
le privé et des chefs d'entreprise ils
étaient entrés et c'est merveilleux mais
qui de qui mieux que le chef
d'entreprise connaît ses collaborateurs
personnes pardon mais et quand on est
quand on discute avec tous les jeux on
l'a dit plusieurs fois à plusieurs
reprises ce matin
en réalité ce n'est pas une négociation
n'a tant pas les nao est ce qu a pas de
négociation annuelle obligatoire pour
négocier avec les salariés
on était là négociations allaient tous
les jours sur tous les sujets et sur
tous les terrains
vous pouviez s'il vous plaît simplifier
les choses entre les délégués du
personnel au chsct de demander s'il vous
plaît l'autorisation pour quasiment
aller aux toilettes s'il vous plaît pour
faire quelque chose quand on est chef
d'entreprise les yeux et je vais y aller
juste après mais ray même est réellement
plus vous allez nous simplifier les
choses plus on va pouvoir embaucher en
fait les 6000 des civils issus des six
millions de chômeurs aujourd'hui et quel
que soit le secteur d'activité ça peut
vraiment se régler très rapidement si on
a le courage politique de les céder chez
à l'entreprise fai et les salariés eux
mêmes aussi avec dernier mot berne et
vaud oui je voulais tourner une chose
c'est que vous avez ici des chefs
d'entreprises qui sont des entreprises
familiales
moi j'ai travaillé dix ans une
multinationale
c'est pas du tout la même chose et là on
est on est beaucoup plus un numéro
alors que chaque personne chez nous est
un individu qui a une importance alors
que dans une multinationale c'est quand
même beaucoup plus difficile simplifier
refonder nous sommes bien sûr cette sur
cette ligne merci à celles et ceux qui
ont participé à ces débats très intense
de ce matin merci aussi à luc ferry qui
est venu éclairer de sa hauteur de de
vue et de chats connaissance de la
philosophie ce qu'est aujourd'hui la
valeur travail et comment elle a évolué
au fur et à mesure des temps la parabole
des talents est une bonne manière de
résumer tout cela maintenant je laisse
la parole à nicolas sarkozy président
des républicains